وقُطعت ساق أحد الحماسيين الآخرين وبُترت ذراعه ويده
تم قطع إصبعيه الثانيين وكان واقفاً على السطح
من مسجد دمر وسوف يفعل وفاز لماذا لأنه
أولاده سيستمرون وأحفاده سيستمرون لأن
لأنه بقي فقد نجا، وبالتالي فهي براءة
يجب أن يُفهم النصر هنا رأسًا على عقب
معايير أخرى للنصر ولكن هنا هناك
نحن نرى ولكن نعم حماس نيكيم يسلمها
وتقول أن هناك نيكيم من حماس استسلم والبعض لم يستسلم
وكم من لا يزال في الأنفاق يخرج بأداة
سلاح للتفجير ولكن هذه القصة ليست كذلك
ما يرونه هنا اليوم، يرونه بعيدًا
ولكننا نرى أيضًا الكثير في المستقبل، آسف لماذا
نحن نتحدث عن الشعب الأبدي وإقصاء الكثيرين
ومن أجل أطفالنا الذين سيواصلون النضال
الأميركيون سيساندونكم دائمًا، أيها الأوروبيون
سيتم دعمك إلى الأبد من قبل المجتمع الإسرائيلي الذي سيعطيك
العودة إلى الأبد، هذه هي الأسئلة المهمة، انظر، هناك
آية في القرآن تقول "اللهم انظر زوجي".
القدرة على التحمل
الزمن
افهم أنه ليس لدينا مثل هذه الكلمة في اللغة العبرية لأنه لا يوجد أي منها
لدينا مثل هذا المفهوم في العبرية، صابر هو الشخص الذي يستطيع
البقاء في نوع هيرش لمدة شهرين أو ثلاثة أشهر لا يرى
مناسب لضوء النهار أو طعام مناسب أو لم يخرج شيء
بالقابض وسوف يقتل اليهود لماذا لأنه يملك
القدرة على التحمل لفترة طويلة العيش داخل البواء
الإسرائيليون يعيشون في سبيل الله، الله معهم
يا مقاتلي الجهاد، نحن مقاتلو حرية إسرائيل، حسنًا
نحن لسنا محاربين من الروح القدس.انظر، كان هناك يوم واحد
سوف ألقي نظرة على تسيبي ليفني هاي في لوحة ما
وقلت لها هنا العنصر الديني هو المسيطر
معهم